bonjour à tous sfr a été condamné en
appel par la justice pour des problèmes
qui peuvent peut-être vous concerné et
on va regarder ça maintenant
sfr a été condamné à verser 30 mille
euros de dommages et intérêts à
l'association ufc que choisir qui ont
des problèmes antérieurs alors
effectivement c'est un procès en appel
il ya déjà une condamnation en première
instance
une condamnation qui a été renforcée et
il ya eu plus de points qui ont été
condamnés par la justice
et c'est ce qu'on va voir tout de suite
parce que sfr est effectivement dans le
collimateur de la justice depuis
quelques années suite à différentes
plaintes de consommateurs et puis
surtout une action qui a été menée par
ufc que choisir alors on va se faire un
petit historique une première
condamnation en première instance pour
une vingtaine de clauses abusives ou
illicites jugé en tout cas à visiter ici
sfr a fait appel bien évidemment à la
cour d'appel de paris qui a confirmé la
condamnation de l'opérateur pour
l'intégration dans ces conditions
générales de clauses jugées illicites et
abusives alors l'opérateur doit
supprimer des classes concernées sous
peine d'une astreinte de 300 euros par
jour sous 12 mois alors effectivement
ils ont largement le temps de modifier
tout ça tranquillement le temps de le
faire d'un point de vue légal
mais s'ils ne le font pas 300 euros par
jour d'un mandant plus et tout ça à
partir du 30 mars 2018
quelles sont les clauses quels sont les
problèmes alors il ya une dizaine
d'articles présent dans les conditions
communes aux offres d'abonnement de mars
2017 qui ont été condamnés et qui sont
reconnus comme abusive ainsi que quatre
articles des conditions générales
d'utilisation de sfr à la carte
à la même date elle juge également
illicites l'ensemble des conditions
générales d'abonnement d'utilisation
entre janvier 2012 et juin 2014 en
raison du caractère illisible de la
typographie qui n'excède pas 3 mm de
haut et oui vous le connaissez déjà tous
eu des contrats des conditions générales
de vente que ce soit votre opérateur
téléphonique les box internet
une autre victime devant vous avez au
dos tout une tartine du conditions
générales que personne ne lit rien le
général et on a largement tort que ce
soit moi ou probablement vous et là
effectivement ils ont été condamnés
parce que les caractères ne vais pas pu
3 mm de hauteur et la justice a reconnu
qu'avec 3 mm de hauteur elle permettait
pas du tout aux consommateurs d'être
réellement averti de pouvoir en prendre
connaissance de façon éclairée donc les
hôtes et condamné là dessus ça en tout
cas c'est vrai que c'est intéressant
parce qu'on voit qu'on a des clauses
sont déjà franchement imbuvable et quand
on écrit en minuscule bien évidemment
vous n'allez pas le lire alors ces boat
soit un siège responsabilités mais à un
moment il faut aussi reconnaître que
les opérateurs quel qu'il soit vous
pousse pas forcément en prendre
connaissance
en écrivant tout petit donc voila un
petit peu un axe de condamnation a
contacté par la fp l'opérateur a rappelé
qu'il s'agissait d'éléments remontant à
la période antérieure au rachat de sfr
par acti ce sont donc des choses qui ont
été modifiée et améliorée oui sfr a été
racheté par altice il ya de ça quelques
temps même s'ils ont été rachetés sfr
altis devoir répondre du procès qui est
fait et sait faire et en assumer les
conséquences derrière mais ils ont
effectivement des nous en tout cas on
fonctionnait pas comme ça ce que veut
dire la réponse est que je ne fonctionne
pas comme ça ce sont des pratiques
anciennes qui ont eu lieu mais que ça ne
les concerne pas et que fonctionne pas
comme ça donc ses discours est là pour
rassurer les clients pour les éviter de
partir et pour dire attention nous on
est clean avec nous vous dresserez rien
alors à savoir que d'un point de vue
légal
sfr a toujours la possibilité de se
pourvoir en cassation alors les clauses
en question maintenant parce que ya pas
que ça sfr s'autorisait 10 % d'échec
d'appel 10 % d'échec de l'envoi de sms
et de data 10 % d'échec c'est quand même
énorme ça veut dire que ils vous disent
en gros nous ne sommes pas responsables
sous un maximum de 10 % d'échec mais 10%
c'est quand même monstrueux c'est un
taux qui est très élevée on n'est pas
sur un consens 0 5 % d'échec qui
pourrait arriver suite à des problèmes
de réseau ou différents pôles techniques
non la 10%
c'est une façon un petit peu de se
dédouaner dire s'il ya des problèmes bas
en réalité c'est pas de notre faute si
vous l'acceptez donc ça ça a été perçu
comme le refus de s'engager sur des
débits minimum et indemnisées
intégralement ses utilisateurs en cas
d'interruption de service oui parce que
l'interruption de service qu'on vous dit
on a jusqu à 10%
ça leur laisse quand même un petit peu
de marche sous le pied pour ne pas avoir
à vous indemniser il ya une condamnation
concernant des frais supplémentaires qui
étaient à votre charge lors de demandes
de changement de mode de paiement
et lorsque vous voulez changer votre
mode de paiement changer de carte bleue
par exemple passer sur du virement ou du
prélèvement ou peu importe vous aviez
des pénalités financières on vous
chargez financièrement les dents
effectivement on fait les modifications
c'est vous qui allez payer sa part
effectivement pas trop normal parce que
lorsque vous payer un abonnement vous
paye également un accès aux services
clients il ya qu'à voir effectivement
avec une différence on parle de se faire
prendre par exemple lutter doit se faire
lorsque vous avez sfr un abonnement
normal vous payez plus cher que lorsque
vous avez excès à sfr raids dans les
points différence vous avez notamment le
fait vous avez pas accès aux services
clients directement par téléphone ça
veut donc dire que lorsque vous avez un
abonnement sfr classique vous payer pour
avoir accès aux services clients pour
avoir accès aux maudits
questions réponses à toutes les
modifications ils rentrent à votre
contrat lorsqu'on vous dit on va vous
chargez on va vous coller des frais
lorsque vous allez modifier votre moyen
de paiement ça paraît effectivement
complètement abusif et ils ont été
condamnés sur ce point là il leur est
également reproché d'empêcher leurs
clients de résilier en cas
d'augmentation des tarifs ou lorsqu'ils
ne peuvent pas accéder aux services
proposés en option en leur imposant des
frais supplémentaires donc ça ça
représente une limitation des droits de
résiliation point de condamnation
supplémentaire
oui la suite inscrit c'est tout noté je
peux tout appris par coeur c'est assez
technique en matière de recours
d'interruption de service le tribunal a
mis en avant que sfr laisser croire à
ses clients qu'il n'avait droit qu'à une
indemnité partiel alors qu'en réalité le
client est en droit de réclamer une
réparation totale de son préjudice et
que l'opérateur limiter ce droit de
recours en restreignant le délai de
réclamation à un mois en plus de ça il
faut savoir que sfr s'est vu attribuer
le cactus d'or 2010 est rien que ça par
l'association 60 millions de
consommateurs pour avoir pourri la vie
de ses clients tout au long de l'année
alors pourquoi cette récompense pourquoi
est-ce que 60 millions de consommateurs
a effectivement visé sfr qui dit c'est
que c'est pour encourager l'opérateur à
redoubler d'efforts pour traiter ses
clients de façon plus décentes en 2018
alors la question maintenant qu'il se
passe c'est peut-on faire confiance à
sfr je sais pas si vous vous avez eu des
problèmes avec eux si oui je vous invite
à tous marqué en commentaire et puis on
pourra échanger à ce sujet là mais
peut-on faire confiance à sfr
aujourd'hui alors pour moi de mon point
de vue je sais pas si vous allez
d'accord mais tout porte à croire que
oui alors je sais ça va en faire rêver
plus d'un surtout si vous avez eu des
problèmes et je vous explique pourquoi
parce que il ya deux choses la toute
première chose c'est qu'effectivement
ssr a été racheté par altice sfr altis
c'est un investissement qui est très
conséquent de la part d'al tice et le
but pour eux c'est effectivement que sfr
soit pérenne que ça ramait du business
de l'argent et ce soit quelque chose
d'extrêmement viable donc l'idée c'est
pas du tout d'avoir un service qui est
d'une très mauvaise qualité parce qu'ils
pourraient avoir d'autres procès
d'autant plus que là il ya quand même un
historique dans la mesure où ils ont été
condamnés en première instance en appel
même si ces provocations
fondamentalement il pourrait être
condamné sur des points similaires s'il
continue dans ce sens dont ils ont tout
intérêt à modifier tout ça et
effectivement sfr altis a dit à des
pratiques été fait avant pas du tout
deux notes faits sont pas des choses que
nous faisons donc en gros vous pouvez
tranquille donc je pense que de ce point
de vue là
c'est assez vrai et puis le deuxième
point c'est une fois que vous avez été
pris la main dans le pot de confiture
dans le pot de miel comme vous voulez
vous si vous recommencez
forcément ça va vous coûter beaucoup
plus cher donc tout intérêt à corriger
le cas pour plusieurs raisons le tout
premier c'est effectivement pour éviter
de voir fondre leurs bases clientèle et
de voir partir les clients une fois de
plus parce qu'ils ont déjà perdu
beaucoup de clients
le deuxième c'est pour pouvoir capter de
nouveaux clients s'ils ont une
réputation qui est très mauvaise il est
très clair que vu la concurrence les
gens n'iront pas chez sfr
et le troisième point c'est essayer de
reconquérir les clients perdus les
clients déçus saas avec le poil plus
difficile parce que chat échaudé craint
l'eau froide une fois que vous avez eu
des problèmes avec un opérateur
vous serez pas envie d'y retourner ou
alors peut-être sous 5 10 en tout cas ça
c'est un gros challenge pour eux donc
est ce qu'aujourd'hui on peut encore
faire confiance à sfr à mon avis on peut
tout ça n'est pas encore terminée avoir
cessé tard ce pourvoi en cassation donc
là ils ont été condamnés effectivement
30000 euros on peut se dire que pour sfr
c'est une pacotille mais si ça continue
ça peut faire des petits ça peut leur
coûter beaucoup plus cher à la longue
ils ont tout intérêt à rectifier le tir
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu des
problèmes avec eux avec un autre
opérateur
ce qui m'intéresse à voir quels forfaits
vous avez parce que ça je pense qu'on
pourra en parler les forfaits
téléphoniques parce que c'est vraiment
quelque chose il ya des grandes grandes
disparités en termes de tarifs
dites moi si ça vous intéresse qu'on
parle des forfaits téléphoniques et puis
que je vous conseille un petit peu sur
les meilleurs forfaits téléphoniques les
bonnes astuces les bons plans pour
trouver les meilleurs forfaits aux
meilleurs tarifs parce que ça je peux
vous assurer que j'ai passé beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de temps pour essayer
de trouver le meilleur forfait alors moi
aujourd'hui j'ai un forfait
internationale qui me coûte 15 euros par
mois international parce que quand je
bouge pour la chaîne youtube et bien
forcément nouveau rapport international
ça évite de se faire déchirer au niveau
de la facture finale donc marquer ma
tout ça en commentaires dites moi ce que
vous en pensez
je vous remercie une fois de plus
d'avoir pris tant de regarder cette
vidéo fut a laissé deux jolies pouces
vous marquez toutes vos suggestions tout
bousiller tout ce que vous voulez en bas
je donne rendez vous très très très
bientôt parce qu'on parlait toujours
plus de produits innovante technologique
et pourquoi pas et pourquoi pas des
conseils pour dénicher son forfait au
meilleur coût
mark et moi tout ça à très bientôt je
vous embrasse n'oubliez pas de vous
abonner à très bientôt soyez sages
twitter
[Musique]